across the world tonight people are
praying that we will learn good news
about the president's condition
over at cnn however we're told again and
again that the president deserved the
sickness that he got
and they trade trotted out the usual
hacks to explain why he deserved it
a lot of people have been put in
jeopardy by the
president's behavior and now we've
learned of course this morning that one
of those people is the president himself
but he just
couldn't get over the fact that in his
mind
the mask equals weakness equals i'm not
on top of this virus so perhaps a bit of
a shock this morning for americans but
not necessarily a surprise
it is also the most vivid possible
demonstration
of the incompetence and the
irresponsibility of the administration
in large part it's his own dereliction
is partly to blame for this he chose to
go out to rallies
imagine he just announced he was
infected
he just got to walter reed he deserved
it
they didn't wait long of course millions
of americans have been diagnosed with
the coronavirus probably people you know
probably people in your family we can
say that
hundreds of thousands have died cnn's
expert panelists are saying
they all deserved it they must have they
were careless they were derelict in
their duties
if there was a lesson from the coverage
of this it's a very familiar lesson
the media class is willing to attack the
rest of the country if they think it
will hurt the president
they despise if they think it will give
them more political power and of course
it wasn't just the media in fact the
official message of the democratic party
is that donald trump had it coming we
all receive that news with great sadness
i always pray for the president his
family that they're safe
i continue to do so more intensified
this is tragic
it's very sad but it also is something
that
that again going into
crowds unmasked and all the rest was
sort of a brazen invitation
for something like this to happen
raised an invitation he asked for it he
was dressed provocatively
that's what nancy pelosi just told you
many other democrats are echoing that
sentiment
rick leventhal has been following this
reaction from the democratic party he
joins us tonight to explain
more rick hey tucker there are a lot of
people wishing the president and first
lady well on twitter sending thoughts
and prayers for a speedy recovery but
no surprise the haters are not holding
back actually saying they hope the first
couple
die and twitter says it's immediately
removing those messages because they
violate policy
here's one from former obama staffer
zara rahim who
shared this and then apparently
self-deleted a post reading it's been
against my moral identity to tweet this
for the past four years
but i hope he dies then there's steve
cox an independent candidate for
california's 39th district who posted
numerous tweets wishing death on the
president
and then wrote by quote i hope they both
die i was talking about trump and biden
not melania she seems nice and former
elizabeth warren staffer max berger
wrote
trump has destroyed millions of lives he
deserves none
of our sympathy some twitter users have
compiled a library of mean tweets
wishing the worst on the president and
there are too many of them to count
tucker
in a statement twitter says content that
wishes
hopes or expresses a desire for death
serious bodily harm or fatal disease
against an individual
is against our rules and twitter says it
will prioritize the removal of content
when it has a clear call to action
that could cause real world harm that's
a quote meanwhile the president's tweet
announcing he had the virus was his most
popular
ever at last count tallying 1.7
million likes tucker unbelievable rick
leventhal
thank you sure if you find yourself
rooting for someone's death
anyone's death it's time to pause and
take stock
of how your own soul has rotted we're
all going to die in the end
and trust me as we do we're going to
regret thinking things like that about
other people
we actually debated whether or not to
put that on the air tonight it's so ugly
in general or our viewers don't put
things on tv that are that ugly
but we felt we should because it is
everywhere today
and we want you to know why there are
some who are rooting for the president's
demise and the vice president's demise
so that nancy pelosi might become
president that sounds insane
and it is but they put it on msnbc
anyway watch
this is a very serious health threat you
are second in line for the presidency
has the white house contacted you about
the continuity of government
cnn had a similar message today
so this is political opportunism
obviously but it's more than that
it's spiritual sickness hatred
festering hatred has driven these people
bananas truly
on cnn today connecticut senator chris
murphy who sits in the united states
senate
proved the point better than we ever
could here's what he said if president
trump can't be out there on the campaign
trail for the next two weeks
then he is going to rely on his
surrogates and unfortunately one of his
surrogates is vladimir putin
so you are likely going to see this
campaign
ramped up by russia over the next few
weeks to try to substitute for the
president's absence on the campaign
trail
i'm sorry again we apologize even for
playing garbage like that the president
united states is in the hospital
with a life-threatening illness he seems
to be fine but you don't know
and that buffoon is on television saying
vladimir putin is one of his surrogates
probably some teenage assistant wrote
that for you thinks it's clever we put
that on the air because we want you to
know what they're saying
as the president was flown to walter
reed tonight what does that even mean by
the way